[Music]
it doesn't matter if you're a muckle or
a wizard Harry Potter fans everywhere
love Hermione Granger Teri's intelligent
feste is a super important part of the
books and movies today we'll take a look
at who hermione is and how she changed
throughout the series
Hermione's Jean Granger is often
referred to as the brightest Witch of
her age hermione is a muggle-born witch
that means that both of our parents are
muggles or non magical people
her parents are dennis which is a
totally weird concept to other wizards
hermione is one of Harry Potter's best
friends and she's the oldest of the
golden trio
according to JK Rowling her birthday is
September 19 1979 this makes her almost
a full year older than Harry but oddly
enough they're in the same year Rowling
put a lot of thought into Hermione's
name her name is the female version of
the Greek god Hermes Hermes was known
for being really smart and also for
fitting into two different worlds that
describes Hermione perfectly at least no
one on the Gryffindor team had to buy
that way and they got it on pure talent
Hermione's Patronus is an otter which
are smart animals that can live in both
water and on land that's just like
Hermione's ability to be successful in
both the muggle and Wizarding World she
adopts a pet cat named
Cruikshank's in the Prisoner of Azkaban
Hermione's wand is made with dragon
heartstrings which is a sign of a very
powerful witch now that we've covered
all the basics about Hermione's let's
dig deeper into who she was in the books
Harry Potter met Hermione very early in
the book in fact she is one of the first
kids in his year that he meets hermione
is introduced in chapter 6 of the
Philosopher's Stone Harry sits with Ron
Weasley in a train compartment neville
longbottom comes by looking for his lost
toad Trevor
then a young girl with bushy hair comes
by she's helping Neville look for his
toad she sees that Ron is attempting to
cast a spell and sits down to watch his
spell fails and she tells him it wasn't
very good she reveals that she has tried
a few spells for practice and they have
all worked
she also says that she has memorized all
their schoolbooks and she goes on to
tell Harry that he is mentioned in three
of the books she reads Hermione is
originally described as bossy she
immediately comes across as a
know-it-all but she desperately wants to
know all about the world that she is in
and she's really smart
not everyone can memorize their
schoolbooks especially at the age of
eleven she loves to read and she's
always at the library
she loves learning just for learning
State you might think Hermione belongs
in ravenclaw that's the house for people
who value intelligence in creativity but
Hermione is a lot more than just smart
she's very kind and we can see that from
the beginning
she helps Neville a boy who she just met
look for his toad Hermione always wants
to help and she's very loyal to her
friends she says she cares about
following school rules but she'll do
just about anything to help out her
buddies and save the world
she set Snape on fire in the first book
to save Harry from the curse bludger she
confronted someone who was trying out
for Quidditch to help Ron get on the
team
it's Hermione's loyalty and bravery that
put her in Gryffindor and Hermione is
super brave she faces off with a
three-headed dog in the first book and
she puts herself in more and more
dangerous situations as the books go on
there's no limit to how far the bookworm
will go to save the people she cares
about Hermione isn't perfect though she
sees the world as very black and white
that's why she butts heads with
professor Trelawney and isn't always
nice to Luna Lovegood she has trouble
believing in things she can't see she
can also be a teacher's pet and a little
self-righteous but at the end of the day
she's a great friend and a total hero in
the books
JK Rowling doesn't talk a lot about
Hermione style here's what we do know
about her appearance though she's
described as having bushy dark hair she
has two front teeth that are very large
in the fourth book a hex from Draco
Malfoy makes her teeth grow extra big
she goes to the hospital wing to have
Madame Pomfrey fix her teeth she has her
shrink them back to normal size so she
no longer has buck teeth Hermione was
obviously teased about her teeth a lot
so she had them magically shrunk
where's her school uniform and school
robes the only times rolling really
describes what hermione is wearing is
when she dresses up for the Yule Ball in
Goblet of Fire
she wears periwinkle blue dress robes
she had used a hair potion to make her
hair shiny and less bushy she fixed it
into a tight and elegant button everyone
thought she looked gorgeous she dressed
up again for bill and fleurs wedding in
the Deathly Hallows
she wore a lilac colored dress and
matching heels once again the witch
tamed her frizzy curls to look more put
together for the special occasion
Hermione definitely likes those pastel
colors the movie producers and costume
designers made a lot of changes to her
my knees looks keep watching to find out
what they changed I've never seen a more
complicated person there are some major
differences between the Harry Potter
books and movies some of the changes
make sense though since it's impossible
to fit an entire book into a single film
but some of the changes are totally
random and hermione is definitely one of
those characters who encountered many
alterations one of the main differences
is her appearance in the first couple of
movies they gave actress Emma Watson
bushy hair but by the third movie her
brown hair was pretty tamed of course
Emma is gorgeous and Hermione is not
supposed to be traditionally attractive
but they didn't know that when they cast
her as a child they changed her style -
at the Yule Ball in the movie Hermione
wears a pink dress and she wears a red
dress at Bill's wedding she's also
pretty trendy she wears a lot of jeans
and sweaters however her clothes were
definitely in style for the 90s which is
when the books take place the movies
also changed a lot in regards to
Hermione as personality sure she's still
what Snape would call an insufferable
know-it-all but she's just a little too
perfect in the movies she basically
doesn't have any flaws and this upset a
lot of fans he wants to kill Harry
you'll have to cut off to a lot of Ron's
best important lines were given to
Hermione she's also a bit of a mother
hen to Harry and she's always nice to
Luna they also took away her whole
storyline of helping house elves another
major change is the reason that she and
Ron kiss in the
book and movie in the book ron is
worried about the house elves hermione
is so happy to see that he cares that
she launches herself at him to kiss him
in the book they're so relieved after
killing poor crepes that they just sort
of mutually kissed hermione is a
passionate person she believes the way
that house elves are treated is totally
unjust in the book she starts the
Society for the Protection of elfish
welfare or spew she spends a lot of her
free time knitting clothes for the elves
to free them without their consent her
heart is in the right place but she
doesn't listen to what the elves won
hermione is just as passionate about her
relationships she's like a sister to
Harry she stays with him through the
worst of times when they're hunting
Horcruxes Hermione can sometimes get on
Harry's nerves but they never really
have serious fights hermione is also
close to ginny weasley
she's able to talk to Jenny about her
love life because Harry and Ron just
don't understand in the series Hermione
has two love stories she dates Viktor
Krum in Goblet of Fire he is her first
kiss and she tells Harry that she and
Viktor don't really do much talking her
other love story is with Ron they fight
a lot throughout the series but ron
challenges her he's smart in a different
way and forces her to think outside the
box he comforts her a lot in Deathly
Hollows she gets insanely jealous when
he dates lavender in half-blood Prince
we were so glad when they finally ended
up together according to Canon the two
get married and have two children we get
to see them in the epilogue of the last
movie happily married if you haven't
seen or read Harry Potter and the cursed
child you might not know about their
family they have a daughter named Rose
and a son named Hugo Ron and Hermione
are just so cute together
Hermione is only 18 years old at the age
of Battle of Hogwarts but she has dealt
with a lot in her life in the first book
she runs off to the bathroom to cry
after Ron makes fun of her behind her
back and she gets attacked by a troll
she faces all the challenges that are
guarding the Sorcerer's Stone in the
Chamber of Secrets Hermione gets
petrified by the bacillus she has the
page about it curled into her hand she
was trying to tell someone what the
monster was Hermione wants to take as
many
as she can because she loves learning in
her third year she's allowed to have a
time-turner she manages to keep up with
twice the amount of schoolwork and still
ends up scoring the best grades she is
the one who encourages Harry to start
Dumbledore's Army in order of the
Phoenix she isn't afraid to break em
bridges rules in order to make sure they
can defend themselves in the war
Romania also tracks down Horcruxes with
Harry in the final installment of the
series that includes impersonating
Bellatrix Lestrange and breaking into
Gringotts uh did we mentioned that she's
brave yes oh okay good just making sure
Hermione has achieved a lot in her life
too
she received outstanding on almost all
of her owl tests in her fifth year she
got an exceeds expectation in defence
against the dark arts she regularly
makes the highest grades she wanted to
get her newts so Hermione return to
Hogwarts after the war to make up the
time she missed she isn't called the
brightest Witch of her age for nothing
how much did Hermione evolved throughout
the series well stay tuned to find out
amazing you boys surprised
at first glance you might think that
Hermione doesn't change much throughout
the story she's always the smartest
person around and she's always brave and
loyal like the average Gryffindor
but Hermione really does grow as a
person in the first book
Hermione doesn't really stand up for
herself but thanks to her friendship
with Ron and Harry she gains more
confidence
she even punches Draco in the face when
he takes things too far
Hermione's biggest fear is failure at
first it's a fear of feeling at school
but later she realizes what's really
important she gets scared of losing her
loved ones and losing the war she
becomes a leader
we don't just mean that she became a
prefect we mean that she is a leader in
the war effort she becomes a best friend
to Harry instead of being condescending
she becomes his closest confidant he
ghoster for more than just book smart
questions he confides his fears to her
and she never fails to lend him a
shoulder to lean on
Hermione's passions changed throughout
the franchise
she continues to take care of those who
can't take care of themselves but she
abandons few she realizes that the house
elves don't want to be freed with no
place to go in this she learns that she
isn't right all the time
she remains passionate about learning
but she also becomes a fantastic soldier
who puts her studies on the backburner
she's able to go undercover at the
ministry she duels Death Eaters and
comes up kicking after she receives
Dumbledore's copy of the tales of the
beetle bark she dives into learning
about the Deathly Hallows this helps
Harry defeat Voldemort
Hermione is strong one of her greatest
strengths is her ability to make
sacrifices she removes herself from her
parents memories to keep them safe not
many people could do that
she stays strong for Harry in the forest
even though she's hurt when Ron abandons
them she puts the mission and the war
first hermione grows a lot when she
begins to realize that she has feelings
for Ron she used to look down at him and
treat him like a dumb-dumb but she
realizes that he's smart in his own way
she's able to forgive him for leaving
during the hunt for Horcruxes she's also
able to overcome her jealousy of
lavender brown both characters mature a
lot throughout the books they would not
have
did if they had gotten together sooner
but the ward teaches Hermione what
really matters she's able to overlook
the things about Ron that bother her
because she loves him
one thing about Hermione that doesn't
change is her allegiance to different
causes and people
Hermione always sides with Harry in
major conflicts even if they disagree
about smaller things she's always
willing to sacrifice herself to help
Harry Hermione is always one of the good
guys she stands up to Snape and in her
own way it stands up to umbrage she
always fights for what is right she
never struggles with her morals because
she knows who she is she could have
stayed out of the war for her own safety
but she didn't she goes against the
ministry once she's convinced that it's
corrupted and she keeps fighting for the
rights of others once the war is over
Hermione Granger goes on to become the
minister of magic but we're not too
surprised about her future
accomplishment especially knowing Ashley
you won't trying to figure the sack out
soggy hermione plays a really important
role in the final battle of Hogwarts
Harry trust her and Ron to destroy the
cup of Helga Hufflepuff while he looks
for the last Horcrux she is able to
destroy that Horcrux because she has
given so much up to find it
Hermione is also a very powerful witch
she helps battle the Death Eaters and
isn't afraid to be right in the middle
of the action she is one of the three
young witches to take on Bellatrix
Lestrange Bellatrix was an extremely
powerful evil witch Romanies duels her
along with Ginny and Luna until mrs.
Weasley finishes her off hermione is
there to comfort Ron after his brother
Fred dies and she's there to support
Harry
after the battle Hermione was important
to the Battle of Hogwarts Voldemort and
the Death Eaters hated muggle-borns they
thought they were less worthy than pure
Bloods but the bright which soon proves
that who your parents are or where your
friend doesn't change a theme she is one
of the bravest and most loyal characters
in the books and she's definitely the
smartest Hermione taught kids everywhere
that it's okay to be smart she taught us
all about friendship and loyalty
Hermione is an important role model for
lots of girls around the
we hope you enjoyed this character
evolution be sure to tell us why you
think Hermione is the greatest in the
comments section and let us know which
Harry Potter character you want us to
cover next give this video a big thumbs
up if you wish the Harry Potter
franchise had never ended and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button for
more magical content thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]